[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to their installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing and comparing
two of the darkest wizards to have ever
disgraced the wizarding world
voldemort and grindelwald each man truly
made his mark on the world of magic
and during different periods of history
were able to instill fear
into the hearts of wizard kind as a
whole during grindelwald's reign of
terror there wasn't a witch or wizard
that didn't know his name
and it wasn't until the year 1945 when
grindelwald was defeated
that the wizarding world could finally
sleep easy however
it just so happens that in that same
year 1945
voldemort was finishing up at hogwarts
meaning that he had already begun to
walk down the very dark path that he
would eventually follow
though the pair never simultaneously
terrorized the wizarding world
the end of grindelwald only meant there
was a brief pause in tyranny
as the first wizarding war began in 1970
when voldemort began his own reign of
terror
1970 marked voldemort's proclamation
that he was the new
dark lord and it was in the same year
that he started to openly perform acts
of evil
around europe though voldemort was
eventually defeated by the potters in
the year 1981
his regime lasted an impressive 11 years
a true testament to the power of
voldemort and his followers
dumbledore who was widely considered to
be the greatest and most powerful wizard
of all time
led the primary opposition against both
wizards and in response to voldemort's
assumption of power in 1970
dumbledore formed the order of the
phoenix in 1971.
dumbledore grindelwald and voldemort
were all immensely powerful wizards
uncomparable to anyone else with the
exception of perhaps some of the fabled
wizards of history
and while voldemort and greenewald both
led impressive regimes
the light did eventually prevail over
each of them but while both dark wizards
eventually fell
there is much debate surrounding
grindelwald and voldemort who was
actually more powerful
both were immensely talented from an
extremely young age and each of them had
exposure to dumbledore
who was said to have been able to do
things with the wand that no one else
could
to better compare them let's take a
brief look at each of their histories
and see if we can pick up any clues
along the way we'll start
chronologically
and begin with galette grindelwald
grindelwald was born in the year 1883
and in his younger years he was a
student at durmstrang institute
while attending the school grindelwald
began to demonstrate exceptional magical
ability
at an extremely young age however his
sadistic nature also quickly showing
through
as not far into his studies he was
expelled for experimenting with twisted
and dark magic
grindelwald was a man that continually
pushed the limits of his magical
abilities
and he didn't let ethical considerations
of good versus bad
magic stop him in his magical endeavors
after being expelled grindelwald was
intent on achieving higher and higher
levels of power
this mission for power eventually landed
him in godric's hollow
england what drew grindelwald to
godric's hollow in the first place
was its connection to the fable of the
deathly hallows a story following three
brothers
antioch cadmus ignotus and their
first-hand experience with the
personification of death
after cheating death death under the
guise of congratulating them
awarded them with three gifts the elder
wand the resurrection stone
and the invisibility cloak long story
short each brother chose one of the
gifts that death had presented them
ignotus the youngest chosen invisibility
cloak cadmus
the middle brother chose the
resurrection stone and antioch
the eldest chose the elder wand it was
expressed that any witch or wizard that
came into the possession
of these three hallows would become
master of death
an all-powerful witch or wizard that
could achieve levels of power
thought previously unattainable i think
that you can probably imagine
why a young girl at grindelwald would be
interested in that
when he first arrived in godric's hollow
he met albus dumbledore
and the two were inseparable as each
young man was immensely magically
talented
they were able to learn a lot from one
another reaching new heights with
regards to magical ability
they had a lot in common each as
ambitious as the other
not only that but both boys shared a
common goal to seek out and acquire
all three of the deathly hallows the
cloak the wand and the stone
not only that but their plan was to lead
a wizarding revolution that would
effectively put an end to the
international statute of secrecy
breaking down the secretive divide
between muggle and magical world
they didn't want to hide in the shadows
they wanted wizard kind who they felt
was superior to humankind to take charge
however things didn't go exactly
according to plan and grindelwald and
dumbledore eventually parted ways
at this point in time grindelwald left
godric's hollow and embarked on his
mission
alone shortly after leaving grindelwald
was actually able to obtain
one of the hallers stealing the fabled
elder wand from one to proprietor miku
gugorovich
this was the beginning of his regime
which operated under the slogan
for the greater good grindelwald grew
immensely in power over the years
and the public opinion quickly became
the dumbledore would be the only man
capable
of stopping him however dumbledore was
reluctant to pursue grindelwald
mainly due to their history together
dumbledore's unwillingness to fight
grindelwald stemmed from a blood pact
the pair had entered in their youth in
which each young man
vowed never to fight the other however
it has been expressed that eventually
grindelwald's actions became just too
terrible for dumbledore to ignore
not only that but his power was reaching
new heights to let him get to a point at
which he could no longer be stopped
would have been massively irresponsible
voldemort's youth was not all too
different from grindelwald's and both
boys grew up without a sense of what
having a normal family was like
voldemort was born in the year 1926 to a
mughal father
tom riddle senior and which mother
murapi gaunt the daughter of marvolo
gaunt
voldemort's conception was very unusual
as the only reason his parents ended up
together
was because his mother used a love
potion on his father
murapi suppressed her magical abilities
for many years but when her father was
imprisoned she felt
liberated and created said love potion
shortly after he drank the potion
tom riddle cenia became infatuated with
merapy and just a few months later
the two were married and murapi was
pregnant with tom's child
this child would later go on to become
lord voldemort
eventually the effects of the love
potion were off which we assume
merapi let happen naturally in the hopes
that he had genuinely fallen in love
with her
he fled and this led merripe down a very
dark path
she fell into a deep dark depression and
on new year's eve in the year 1926
she went to an orphanage and gave birth
to her son tom
marvolo riddle voldemort maripi died
shortly after riddle was born
after suffering from a broken heart and
because she was not there to give tom
love and care
he grew up without any concept or notion
of love
in the year 1938 dumbledore sought out a
young tom riddle at wool's orphanage in
london
and brought the troubled young magical
prodigy to hogwarts
from an extremely young age riddle
showcased intensely powerful innate
magical abilities
he was a magical prodigy if you will and
as he grew older he began to harness his
abilities
in fact he became unimaginably powerful
performing feats of magic that people
thought previously impossible
and he knew it too proclaiming to harry
in the heir of slytherin
that he was the greatest sorcerer in the
world but
was he really or was he ousted out of
that title by dumbledore and grindelwald
voldemort went on to achieve some
extremely impressive feats of magic
the most notable of which was probably
his creation of horcruxes
whether creating horcruxes is actually
difficult or just very morally frowned
upon
is unclear but i expected it probably
involves a bit of both
so both voldemort and grindelwald were
magical prodigies from a young age
that led their own tyrannous regimes but
who would have been harder to stop
let's see what they're capable of with
his innate magical capabilities and
thirst for knowledge
voldemort achieved many impressive feats
of magic over the course of his life
including but not limited to things like
unsupported flight
legitimacy horcrux creation and mastery
of offensive spells
like fiend fire and avada kadavra at
least these are the things that we see
on display
coming from voldemort while voldemort's
skills were impressive
from the outside perspective it really
does seem as though grindelwald knew
more
grindelwald had an extremely impressive
magical arsenal and though some of the
spells that he cast were also achievable
by voldemort
there were also plenty of spells that i
don't think voldemort ever knew
both mastered the unforgivable curses
crucio
imperio and avada kadavra and both men
were masters at transfiguration
however grindelwald's collection of
offensive spells
really seems to dwarf voldemort's
similar to dumbledore grindelwald was a
master of elemental magic
and in the fantastic beasts films that
we've seen so far
he has produced all sorts of lightning
bolts white elemental blasts tempest
jinxes
and even grindelwald's piers de
resistance protego diabolica
i honestly don't think that i've ever
seen a spell as overpowered as protego
diabolica
and if you can't remember what it is
i'll give you a quick reminder we first
see grindelwald use protego diabolica in
the lestrange mausoleum
protego diabolica is a dark spell that
creates a ring of protective black fire
around the target
anyone who is the enemy of the caster
will be instantly incinerated when they
try to enter the circle
the possibilities of this spell seem
endless as it is not just a static
circle of flames
we see grindelwald controlling the spell
like a weapon extending ten trills of
black flames towards his enemies
with these ten drills grindelwald was
able to prevent auras from escaping the
mausoleum
via apparition the spell eventually
escalates into what can only be
described as a fiery winged demon
similar to fiendfire it's a completely
ridiculous spell
that is simultaneously offensive and
defensive and outclasses any of the
spell that we've seen before in harry
potter
that spell alone really gives him some
extra points against voldemort
however what should be mentioned is that
the grindelwald we see in the films
possessed the elder wand
voldemort didn't have the elder wand
until the end of the harry potter films
and even then he wasn't the true owner
and couldn't properly master the wand
grindelwald was the genuine owner of
what is considered to be historically
the most powerful wand in history and so
it only makes sense that with it
he was able to produce magic previously
unheard of is this the sole reason that
he could produce
such absurd magic that's anyone's guess
but it's definitely a consideration that
needs to be made
when comparing these two dark wizards a
counter argument for this is the fact
that voldemort
who didn't even possess the elder wand
was able to effectively duel dumbledore
supposedly the most powerful wizard of
all time while he bore the elder wand
and given that an elder wandless
dumbledore defeated an elder wand
bearing grindelwald
this seems like a point for voldemort in
the harry potter films
after harry is finished looking into the
pensive observing dumbledore's first
interaction with the young tom riddle
he has the following exchange with
dumbledore did you know sir
then did i know that i had just met the
most dangerous dark wizard of all time
no whether or not this is an admittance
that voldemort is the most dangerous
wizard of all time
is not 100 clear but i'm willing to bet
there's some truth behind dumbledore's
statement
most dangerous doesn't necessarily mean
most powerful as one could be less
powerful
and more destructive but i think that
this honestly might be another point for
voldemort
and this is where the two dark wizards
differ quite a lot vodal was certainly
the more destructive of the two
but again this doesn't mean that he was
more powerful grindelwald had a lot
more humanity than voldemort and while
he was evil to some degree
he did have a concept of things like
love and happiness
voldemort's only joy came from doing
terrible things
he was never happy or loved even in
childhood and so when he got older
he had no concept of either grindelwald
on the other hand
did find love in his life and his
ambitions of establishing a new world
order
were not primarily driven by notions of
evil or darkness
even if it looked that way at times
grindelwald genuinely felt that what he
was doing was important for the world
and that is why his slogan was for the
greater good he recognized that a lot of
his actions were wrong
but ultimately believed that his mission
to establish the global wizarding
hierarchy
was important for wizard kind he felt
that he was just helping
his people even if it did oppress
another people
this is perhaps the only reason why
grindelwald never created horcruxes
he enjoyed life and wanted to preserve
his humanity
but wasn't preoccupied with the pursuit
of immortality
producing dark magic like a horcrux
comes at a price
and voldemort was willing to do whatever
it took here he says
himself i have experimented i have
pushed the boundaries of magic
further perhaps than they have ever been
pushed i think to truly determine which
of these two wizards is more powerful
we first need to see how exactly
dumbledore defeats grindelwald
we know that there are three more
fantastic beasts films on the way
and the dumbledore eventually beats him
but whether he received external help or
not
is unclear if dumbledore is genuinely
able to defeat an elder wanding wielding
grindelwald
without possessing the elder wand
himself then i think that it would
definitively mean that voldemort is more
powerful than grindelwald
however i'm far more impressed with the
magic that i've seen
from grindelwald he just seems so in
tune with his abilities
he's cool calm and collected and he
seems to always have things under
control
voldemort at least later in life always
seems like he's being pestered and
outsmarted by other people
and in that respect grindelwald seems
like he's more on top of things
for now i'm going to just have to say
that i think that grindelwald and
voldemort are equals
and i'm going to have to revisit this
topic at a later date when we see just a
little bit more of grindelwald on screen
i always used to be of the impression
that voldemort was just the most
powerful
period but i just can't ignore what
grindelwald was able to achieve
in the latest films what do you guys
think who is more powerful
voldemort or grindelwald let me know
down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
howdy
you